50 shades of gray is directed by Sam
taylor-johnson and is based off of the
internationally best-selling book of the
same name now really quick first off I
want to say hello to all the new
subscribers who have come on since my
problem with action movies today video
first off thank you so much for
subscribing
I'm flattered with how many people
really liked that video and I apologize
and this is the first new review you get
to see but I do try to see everything
because I love what I do but not tonight
the film is about a young woman named
Anastasia Steele who fills in for her
friend who has a cold for about 5
minutes in the movie just so she can get
the position that her friend was gonna
have which is interview
Christian Grey a very successful
businessman and she of course falls for
him and he really happens to like BDSM
bondage and various sexual things ropes
and stuff like that you guys know what
I'm talking about and she embarked on a
journey of sexual discovery that's what
this movie is about and the author
adapted it from her Twilight fan fiction
just so you know originally the author
of the book has since come out and
saying look I wrote a Twilight fan
fiction about various fantasies that I
had people liked it I changed the names
I made a book out of it and now she's a
millionaire that's how it works in this
world apparently now look it's really
easy to go into this movie ready to hate
it and I'll be honest I did not want to
see this movie at all why would I that
being said I tried to keep an open mind
and there are two praiseworthy things
about this movie in my opinion that is
Dakota Johnson I can see her being
really good in a movie that was equally
as good that's not this movie though and
the movie looks really good it's a well
shot and a well lit movie but you know
what you could do if you got a really
good director of photography and he went
out to the street and he found a pile of
rat shit he could probably light that
very well and perhaps shoot it with an
interesting angle but it's still rat
shit Fifty Shades of Grey this movie is
a 2-hour softcore porn with way more
story than you ever care to see in a
porn and tons and tons of the cheesiest
dialogue since the last why light movie
this
movie is considerably more melodramatic
than Jupiter ascending even and that
movie was cheesy as hell but I really do
have major issues with this film the
number one being the betrayal of
Anastasia Steele this is yet another
weak female character who requires a man
a big strong powerful man who's rich and
famous and likes to whip people in the
ass to make her happy she can't be happy
on her own she needs that man she can't
do anything without that man when he's
gone she can't think about anything else
but him and doesn't feel complete with
this female character and Jupiter Jones
and her weak absolutely requiring
Channing Tatum to rescue her every two
seconds character we are seeing some
really awful weak-ass female characters
what do you writers doing out there come
on give some better roles to women I'm
serious this is actually pissing me off
and I'm a dude it's also extremely easy
to see the parallels with Twilight for
one she has a best friend named Jose who
just might as well be Jacob because he
kind of likes her too and that's kind of
throwing a love triangle into the mix
Christian takes her out flying and it's
so fun for her similar to how Edward put
Bella on his back and jumped around the
trees and despite the fact that
Christian continuously tells her that he
is not good for her that he is not the
one for her that you should stay far
away from him she keeps on coming back
just like Edward and Bella it's
abhorrent how this is literally Twilight
just with BDSM let's talk about it
because you want to know what I think
about it the sex scenes they're there
they're pretty racy for a rated R that's
for sure but the problem with this movie
is she isn't into it he is she just
keeps letting him do stuff to her for
his own pleasure even though she doesn't
even enjoy it that's how weak of a
character she is and it's really sad
look I'm not gonna waste my time talking
about this movie anymore because I'm
more than likely gonna have to see two
more because there's two more books and
the movie of course ends on a
cliffhanger with tons of arcs just
hanging in the air waiting to be
completed this movie's horrible I hated
it it's a well shot semi well acted
movie that's a total piece of garbage
and I cannot stand it fifty Shades of
total fucking shit gets an F
oh yeah so I won a fifty Shades of Grey
prize pack at the screening that's right
I won a raffle let's see what's in it
Wow it's a fifty Shades of Grey poster
oh it's the 50 shades of grey t-shirt
curious no I'm really not actually what
the hell
oh it's lip balm okay
it's a lip balm I thought this was
something else huh it's a candle
I like candles but not ones with Fifty
Shades of Grey written on them I really
wish I had this blindfold when the movie
was playing well guys what are your
thoughts on this whole thing let me know
below I'm curious to know if you did see
the movie don't though because it's just
gonna give it money and then they'll
make more I saw it at a screening so I
didn't give them any money yes as always
guys thank you so much for watching and
I am going to check out Kingsman don't
worry I'm actually excited to see that
movie hubby review for that very soon
thank you as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck Benoist
you